Linear programming is largely just the
generalization of this sort of problem
solving to n dimensions, instead of
just the two that we've seen so far.
We can write our optimization
problem in a form like this one.
In matrix form this becomes
maximize c transpose x
such that A x is at most b and
x is nonnegative.
Note that inequality,
when applied to matrices,
means that it holds for
each element in the matrix.
When we first encounter a linear
programing optimization problem
it might not be in this form.
In fact the only requirements for
an optimization being a linear program
is that both the objective function and
the constraints be linear, whether
they are inequalities or equalities.
If this is true, then we can always
turn it into a canonical form like this.
Here are the key transformations, to
convert a max problem to a min problem,
or vice versa, just negate the vector c,
which contains the coefficients for
the objective function.
Thus, max c transpose x becomes
minimizing -c transpose x,
and minimizing c transpose x
becomes maximizing -c transpose x.
To convert an upper bound to
a lower bound, or vice versa,
in one of the constraints,
we simply negate the inequality.
We can convert an equality into two
inequalities by giving both an upper and
lower bound constraint.
Here I have played the trick
from transformation
to make these both at most constraints.
Things get a little more interesting
when we go from one of the inequalities
to an equality.
Here, we introduce a new variable,
either a slack or
a surplus variable,
depending on the inequality.
There's also the problem of
free variables that
are allowed to be negative.
There are two ways to
cope with one of these.
If it is involved in
an equality constraint,
then we can often simply
eliminate it through substitution.
Otherwise you can replace it with
two new non-negative variables, and
just substitute the difference for
x everywhere.